and so we're going to talk about a
couple of these things the first thing i
got we got to talk about man
and this can be a part of just democrat
cities in general
but this to me is one of the most
nightmarish and shocking things i've
ever seen an american politician do in
my life and maybe
maybe that's just my naivety because i'm
34 maybe something happened at some
point i guess
you know we had politicians literally
shoot each other a couple hundred years
ago so
mayor authorizes city to shut shut off
power at hollywood hills party house
reportedly belonging to tick-tock star
bryce hall despite several warnings this
house has turned into a nightclub in the
hills hosting large gatherings in
flagrant violation
of our public health orders garcetti
said
so that's that's just the story look at
this he says with more than two thousand
angelenos
and over 170 000 americans lost to covet
19 we need every resident to undertake
critical safeguards
to stop the spread of this virus that
includes not hosting or attending
parties that put themselves their
neighbors and many others at risk
despite several warnings the house
turned to a nightclub the city has now
disconnected utilities at this hou this
home to stop
these parties that endanger our
community if we wish to reopen more
businesses return our kids to school or
get back to our normal lives
we must continue to wear masks wash our
hands frequently and as we're
emphasizing today
avoid gathering with others all of these
actions save lives
sure actually the dude put out a tick
tock it's kind of funny
uh he posted tic tac wednesday with to
the song electric love because
it looks like the power's out i'm just
gonna say i'm not super concerned about
a rich dude who owns multiple houses who
wants to have big parties in the hills
my concern is the precedent being set
where the mayor did this and no one said
anything
and you're never gonna see a politician
walk out and say i'm going to violate
human rights
it's going to start with this everyone's
going to say that's okay the next day
he's going to say well what about this
celebrity
that's okay within a month he's going to
be like this small family you know this
middle middle class family we're turning
your power off next
they shouldn't have the ability to
arbitrarily shut off someone's utilities
and i think this is this this story hits
several things one mismanagement of
cities
predominantly run by democrats and the
authoritarianism that's emerged
since kovid where they think they can do
anything and to be honest nobody's
stopping him
it's i think what's so troubling for
people it's all confusing
right like go out and protest it's no
problem
have a party at your house that's a
problem we're going to let the protests
happen
have a gathering at your house we're
going to stop it
covet is so bad that we're temporarily
suspending
all utility shutoffs for people right
unless we decide we're going to turn off
your utilities and that's terrifying to
me man
that made me realize that no matter
where i am in the city
i have nowhere to retreat to i have
nowhere to go
where they can't get me they can get me
just in my house in my home
doing whatever i want in washington dc
the other day there was a party
advertised
like flyers on the internet everything
it was like a block party
and uh there was like a ton of people
there and the cops were actually on
scene
didn't break it up really and that what
happened there that was where that mass
shooting was
so like there was 21 people got shot at
this gathering that the cops knew about
so
what i'm getting at here is that there's
just this inconsistent application of
the rules
and that makes people insane because
then they don't know what reality is
or how to behave or how you know what we
all depend on is
is uh predictability by other people and
if your government is acting in an
unpredictable fashion
that could jeopardize your ability to
you know bathe feed
and clothe yourself and take care of
your family well that's a very
unsettling place to be
and where do people take those fears out
maybe they act out but maybe they're
gonna do it in the uh
in the election booth this year i hope
so and i think that's going to be
if man i'm kind of worried about what
happens if trump loses
because we've seen what these states
have done new jersey new york
pennsylvania they're putting sick people
in nursing homes people are dying you
look at what la's doing
you look at what oregon is doing 83
nights now they've allowed these rides
to go on because the d.a keeps releasing
them
apparently you know someone emailed me
saying look look at the court record
somebody got charged with five felonies
the d.a just cut them loose
that's that's how the riots don't stop
this is this is what they are doing
i couldn't imagine what would happen if
that political party
takes control of the executive branch at
this time
and then you know do you see that viral
video from shasta county california
where the guy
says we're being regular americans are
being peaceful now
but he's like you know he basically says
civil war is coming yeah
yeah again it's this predictability man
i just don't know what's going to happen
or what they're going to do to me
or where things are going to go and that
leaves me very unsettled how do you
invest in the future how do you decide
to have a family how do you
build a community when you don't have
any idea the way the law is going to be
applied
if there's going to be laws if like it's
all up in the air but
the troubling thing is really tim i
think we just are acknowledging this
are things going to get worse if trump
loses probably
are things going to get worse if trump
wins probably
that's a little dark though i mean no i
don't think electing trump is going to
stop anything he might begin to chip
away at some of it but imagine the
reaction
for sure you have the other side yeah
you know it's crazy now they
they're trying to bring russiagate back
and that just shows you that there's
there's disparate realities but but i do
think
if trump gets reelected he's untethered
right now
his first four years was do what i can
in a you know tempered way
and then when it comes to re-election
unleash the beast and that's that's what
obama
said right remember when that famous you
know hot mic where he's like i'll have
more flexibility once i get reelected
yeah yeah because they know it's their
last term
right i think i think lame duck is such
a misnomer in fact it's probably
subterfuge when they say that a
president's lame duck because he's on
his way out no way man
that's when they can be most aggressive
that's why all those pardons and
i almost said the bad word that's why
all those pardons and things
uh happen you know at the last minute at
the 11th hour
right it's because they're on their way
out the door and they're less
accountable at that point so i for one
would like to see more aggressive
behavior out of trump i read a fantastic
piece in the claremont river
review of books by michael anton and he
said there's not there's no problem
today that more trump
won't solve and i think he's probably
right
you know more aggressive towards china
you know more nationalism more
patriotism more onshore manufacturing
all kinds of stuff
yeah that he has been hamstrung on
in terms of these cities especially
though trump could invoke the
insurrection act
and he could end it overnight we i don't
know if you saw this what happened
with the guy trying to cut the uh the
breaks to the nypd vehicles
yeah that story no he was accused i'll
say you know innocent until proven
guilty i'm a big fan
but uh the the nypd arrested the guy
they had an informant drive him around
he went to a van he tried snipping the
brake line he didn't
they arrested him local local judge cut
him loose
the feds swooped in immediately and
arrested him on federal charges
and there this was really interesting
i'm not a lawyer but you know i'm
reading this affidavit from the fbi
agent and he says
that it's their jurisdiction because
nypd vehicles are used for interstate
commerce
like the feds don't have jurisdiction in
local affairs in state affairs but they
made one up and it's scary to me because
for one i don't want the federal
government to be able to just
arbitrarily assert jurisdiction
in state and local matters but the state
is
not they're not prosecuting these people
there have been instances in history in
which
federal assertion authority domestically
using the military was done for a good
cause
right i remember watching most recently
a documentary on a u.s
grant and this guy he sent the army
into the south to end the hangings and
to end
to end the kkk right because they were
in the anthem of what we were doing
antifa and these guys they are anathema
to what we are doing there is historical
precedent to use force in a way to
restore the peace
that honors our constitution the bill of
rights and all the things that we hold
dear
uh and then you know what happens after
that is the question
i'm not saying i'm advocating for
because you know me tim i'm i'm
small government you know i i went to
libertarian university george mason i
hate the idea of the feds getting
involved in our business
yeah but at the same time if your state
is just failing to take care of people's
lives and property
life liberty and pursuit of happiness
fail to be protected
then who who who do you call so the
riots i think are
are an easy call but what about what
garcetti is doing in la do you think
trump
the feds should intervene and shut down
you know what what they're doing
in this capacity i'm not a lawyer so i'm
going to punt that one but what are they
going to do they're going to order them
to just stop managing their other
their utilities in the way that they see
fit i mean when they wanted to get
the drinking age raised to 21 across the
country they withheld i think like
highway funds
right they're like we're not going to
give you this money to build your
highway until you raise the drinking age
of 21. yeah
and i think that worked so there are
like levers that you can pull
mostly around money right but imagine if
trump cuts off all the money to
california to get them to turn the guy's
water back on i mean
it's in a way i would be all for it
right like
you can't turn my i paid my bill like
i'm a human being i'm allowed to drink
water we all are
it's a utility it's monopoly it's
regulated it's there to provide a
service and by the way
the official policy is to not cut off
utilities in this time of crisis it's
also like
the policy is to let people out of jails
and they're literally arresting people
and putting them in jails for like
running a business or something
right nothing it's like you said it's
it's asymmetric enforcement of the law
right right and and the enforcement is
on things that we
need as humans for example we need
human interaction socialization and
community to be happy healthy actualized
creatures
we need that but they're banning it we
need to exercise and work out
and be fit and healthy but they're
banning that we need it
why are they attacking all the things
that we do to help us
to help our health to help our sanity
but isn't isn't this for the most part
democrats
i think it is almost exclusively yeah
there have been some republican states
that have had lockdowns but they've been
minor
or none entirely i mean south dakota
rejected trump's stimulus offer
because they were like it's okay most of
our people have returned to work so we
don't need the bonus
i love looking at south dakota it is
definitely an extreme example given how
big it is and how few people live there
uh
their governor though i could i could
definitely see supporting her in the
future in some larger endeavor
she's got the whole package man she
really does should be fantastic
i could support her in future elections
christine you think you run for
president
i mean i watched that speech she gave at
mount rushmore and i was like am i
tweeted out that night when can i vote
for you for president wow
they threw a parade for her so for those
that aren't familiar she refused to lock
down
and south dakota was one of the there
was this chart released i fact checked
me on this one
i saw this chart i was talking about gdp
all of the states are negative
south dakota was was like .08 percent
positive like at a time of crisis
and like you said it's an extreme
example it's it's you know not so much
of a dense population relative to new
york or whatever
but she she did what was right for her
state and the media was relentlessly
attacking her
saying it was the new hot spot it was
you know cove was out of control it
wasn't
it was i looked at the numbers from john
hopkins and it was like right in the
middle
so you had the worst country the worst
state in the country is new york
and then it was like ranked 27 south
dakota like it's not even it was right
there in the middle so it's not an
outlier
but because she was defiant the media
just went
you know which is totally relentless i
think that's a big you know ally of the
democrats obviously
they just push the same narrative right
well the narrative is what matters facts
don't matter
right and wrong don't matter human
rights don't matter your personal
well-being and safety don't matter your
personal happiness and health don't
matter
consistency logic and reason they don't
matter
honoring the constitution and the law of
the land that doesn't matter
federalism that doesn't matter states
right that doesn't matter
i got a real funny story for you hit me
so uh recently
a friend of ours who is not from america
you know
i you know we're hanging out and she
said hey i have a question
the second amendment says the right to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed and i was like right and she
goes
then why can't you have a gun and then
everyone started laughing
because it was like from the outside you
see the second amendment and you're like
that's clear
and then you actually come to the states
and you're like okay so the constitution
doesn't matter
that's correct yeah yeah that's correct
yup we can talk about guns later if you
want there's
a really big case that came out of the
ninth district that allows for uh you
know uh
greater than ten magazines and around
magazines and yep
and in dc where i live those are
strictly prohibited so hopefully
that will uh that will get turned over
yeah i think you know i bring up second
amendment more so as
a general issue of the constitution
which is swiss cheese yeah
it's it is one way to put it i mean
they've punched so many holes in that
it actually scares me how you you know
it really does come back
to for more so the democrats but
republicans
as well it's you know our current system
of governance is disrespectful to the
constitution
you've got people saying you know it's a
living document and i respect that
because we do amend it we do make
changes and we do interpret
but certain things i look at and i've
been i've been much more of a
constitutionalist as of the past year or
so
especially with how the democrats have
been violating people's rights
and i really gotta say look maybe it's
because i live in new jersey and this is
one like probably the worst state in the
country
in terms of the authoritarian lockdown
you know that adolescent gym
yeah they're right down the street oh is
that really yeah it's super close
and these those guys who got arrested
had their business like
license taken away i watched that guy
bust down the door to his
own gym i love that guy i mean dude go
for it like stand up for what's right
this so you know before we started
recording we were talking about we need
meaning
in our life and what's interesting about
these covet lockdowns and all this
tension
is actually giving meaning to some
people who are finding it in resisting
this stuff that they're finding meaning
and resisting it
and like this guy now had he had a
mission of helping people get healthy
and fit but now he's got a mission of
standing up for himself and for what's
right and for his community
like he's this guy's inspired and he's
willing to take risks and put himself at
risk
and i admire that i admire people that
are willing to stand up for what they
believe to be true
not just true today but
like universal truths that transcend
history
right like these people should be free
to get healthy
think about it if you're fit you are
less likely to get sick and die that's
just obvious
now i will i will add my thing is follow
the law
you know i i guess you can say within
reason because i'm i'm actually a big
fan of civil disobedience non-violent
because i think that's where we as a
society accept people push the line
for this guy to kick his door in that's
non-violent civil disobedience i mean
you could argue that kicking the wood
that he put up off
or i think i don't know if the city did
it or not yeah i think they did yeah
you you could argue you're getting close
into vandalizing property or whatever
but it's a piece of ply board
it's his property right right right and
so i look at this and i look at the
bevel and beady when she threw the
the paint on the black lives matter in
new york yeah non-violent civil
disobedience
now i'll tell you this if we were in
normal times
and someone showed up and kicked in the
ply board on a building
and came in i'd be critical of it not
super critical i'd just be like you know
look follow the law
there's there's better ways to do this
but now you've got antifa going around
tearing down statues and the democrats
say it's
peaceful protests you actually had a a
state democrat
in virginia charged with two felonies
for conspiring to tear down the stat to
tear down one of these statues
that actually fell in a dude's head and
nearly killed him dang
so when you actually have i mean you
literally have democrat politicians
joining in
planning this stuff engaging in all the
stuff you want me to be critical of a
dude who kicked his own
you know jim doran or when the democrats
in california are shutting off your
access to
water the most important thing that we
have
water is life yeah don't get it no and
that's that's
that's where so so just to clarify too
they're they're inching towards it
that's my fear
they've authorized the determination of
the utilities here they
shut off it says power i just want to
make sure everybody you know but
my he's straight up said he said we'll
shut off your power and electricity
at a press conference got it so they're
they've it's like pointing the loaded
gun
of a human rights violation at your face
and this
is them cocking the hammer back when
they go to this guy
the u.n said taking away water from
people because they can't afford to pay
the bill is a human rights violation
but taking it away from them because you
want to crack the whip over their heads
that's okay
that's okay yeah that's okay and i think
one of the things that we're feeling too
is just like there's lawlessness right
so when when
they uh tore down a statue in dc i was
out of town
thankfully because god knows if i would
have been there i might have been there
and what would have happened
and i i had this feeling of just being
violated
right there are people just running
around the city tearing things down
destructing things destroying things
taking the law into their own hands
vigilantes basically
and uh when you do when you have this
instability instability this unstable
feeling
you know there's it just disrupts all
parts of your life which is why we all
need to focus more on our health
and our nutrition and our sleep because
we have to be actually physically strong
and resilient
to deal with this because it is a
psychological warfare that they're
playing on us
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you